hey youtubers is Charlie congratulations
to everyone that's made it to the Doctor
Who world tour stops so far they've been
to Cardiff in London they're headed to
Seoul South Korea next but some of you
guys even got some selfies with Capaldi
and Jenna Louise Coleman so
congratulations I even got a shout-out
from the official Doctor Who people on
one of my previous videos so they made a
very special request so I'll explain
that at the end of this video because
it's gonna be a completely separate
thing the biggest new so far I think to
come out of the world tour is that Peter
Capaldi has officially signed on for
series night so he'll be here for at
least two series I think it's possible
to tell an interesting story in just one
series Christopher Eccleston did it but
now that Capaldi has two full years to
develop this character I think it's
gonna get a lot more interesting this
video is mostly gonna be about the big
things that Moffat has been saying and
not saying about series 8 but I will
mention some series 9 things that I hope
to see the biggest things aside from
Capaldi obviously is signing on for a
new series for Moffat being really
upfront about a certain big villain
being dead and gone and a new spin-off
that they're trying to slip through the
cracks in the universe but in case any
of you guys are just finding me for the
first time I do weekly Doctor Who videos
I'm even doing a weekly giveaway during
series 8 all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video so important stuff first if
you have seen any of the screenings of
episode 1 in Cardiff or London or if you
watch the leaked please use spoiler tags
when commenting about it there's a brand
new title sequence and yes it is
glorious it's way different from Matt
Smith's intro Peter Capaldi's doctor is
the end to Matt Smith's fairy tale era
so anyone who quit the show during the
Matt Smith era will probably enjoy Peter
Capaldi's doctor at least until they
find something new to complain about
because he's coming back in 2015 for
series 9 expect the same themes to
continue from series to series it's
still Moffat running the show so using
Matt Smith's run for a comparison the
tone of the show did not change too much
between series 5 and 7b
it was always a fairy tale relationship
comedy you just noticed it more whenever
River Song was around I know a lot of
you guys are wondering if forever song
is gonna return during series 8 she
wasn't the big person that Moffat was
talking about you know not returning but
he has made some comments about her in
the past
previously he's just said the name of
the doctor you know during 7b was her
finale as fans we can have some fun in
theory craft but
all intents and purposes do not expect
to see her during series 8 whenever the
episodes do start airing I will mention
anything that I considered to be a River
Song Easter Egg but I don't think that
she's gonna be coming back anytime soon
what I'm really excited about is the
more introspective approach of series
eight Capaldi's doctor into darkness as
the trailer implies it's gonna be the
MacGuffin from series 8 and I'm
expecting it to continue through to
series 9 there will be a lot of familiar
things but even if a lot of the
characters and plots get shuffled I'm
expecting it to be a much more
psychological approach to the character
it's all about the darkness inside the
doctor we will have to wait till we see
the episodes to see how they're gonna
deal with it but I honestly think it's
gonna be the most interesting thing
about the new series spoiler people
please remember to use tags if you've
already read the scripts ahead they
actually did release a clip from episode
I didn't want to flat-out post it
without a spoiler warning so careful if
you don't want to know anything about
episode 2 just get for it in the video
about 30 seconds I'll wait just a minute
okay everybody ready here we go the
episode 2 clip was them messing with the
broken Dalek I haven't read the script
but the footage was from a promo cut
with a generic Capaldi interview on BBC
one these promos don't usually run in
the United States so if you are a UK
person just let us know in the comments
if they normally use footage from future
episodes ahead of time during promos
like these the trailers that they
circulate are usually less spoilery but
whatever the journey into the Dalek is
just a literal way to interpret that
journey into darkness usually in the
past whenever the doctor messes with
Dalek innards he's trying to access
their data core to get information
physically travelling inside a Dalek as
a whole other thing
it's like taking a magic school bus ride
to hell the use of Daleks actually
brings up an interesting point I think
the biggest complaint I've seen so far
against series 8 is the reuse of
familiar villains and characters for the
most part that's true they are using a
lot of familiar things we've seen the
Cybermen from the finale the Daleks in
the trailer and the Paternoster gang
it's even implied that the clockwork
droids from girl in the fireplace are
back that was actually from Russell T
Davies run but technically Stephen
Moffat wrote that episode so he's the
one that created them I don't mind the
idea of seeing familiar characters as
long as they're done in a very different
way the only time I think it takes you
out of the episode is when it's
something that you just saw in the
previous episode like if there were
Daleks everywhere in the series 8
premiere I'd be a little disappointed
but I did not mind a Dalek in episode
- given that we're gonna see it in a way
that we've never seen it before but you
guys let me know is there anything for
Matt Smith's run that would make you
very upset if you saw it again in series
8 I know River Song is like the biggest
polarizing figure ever in the history of
the fandom just based on the previous
comments I've seen out of my videos it
seems like half of you guys really hated
her in the other half really loved her
but if there's anything besides her that
you feel really strongly about just
write it in the comments
the longer the Doctor Who continues as a
series the harder and harder it's gonna
get for them to do something that's
never been done before
from the early reports I've been seeing
from that first episode people are
saying that Capaldi is a very thoughtful
if not welcome analog to the third and
fourth doctors which totally makes sense
Jon Pertwee was his childhood doctor
during that run he even wrote his own
fanfiction scripts and set them into the
Doctor Who office he did it so much that
it impressed Barry Letts the producer at
the time who invited him to the BBC
offices to meet the third doctor and
Terrance dicks dicks was actually the
script editor during those years so he
might have actually read those Capaldi
fan scripts I know nowadays there's
always the joke that whenever you send
fan scripts in to certain TV shows they
just throw them in the trash but I love
the idea it's so adorable that the BBC
people actually read Capaldi scripts it
would be so amazing if they organised an
official cast reading of those fan
scripts with all the actors role playing
the parts they could even get Sean
Pertwee from the Musketeers to play his
father's role I think it'd be a little
too on-the-nose to have Capaldi play the
third doctor I think he would have been
somewhere between the ages of 13 and 16
whenever he wrote all those scripts I
don't know which year he actually
visited the offices but all you
teenagers out there writing fanfiction
on tumblr keep it up if it's good
someone will notice that brings up a
really interesting issue people inside a
fandom becoming part of the Canon later
a lot of times actors like Peter
Dinklage on Game of Thrones stay
completely away from the source material
just so it won't influence their take on
the character but in Capaldi's case I
think it totally works Doctor Who is
meta science-fiction it totally makes
sense that a 2000 plus year old person
would mix and match references and
affectations from previous lives but let
me know if you guys agree do you think
that a super fan of Doctor Who would
make a better doctor than someone who
has never seen it before he had the big
takeaway from the early episode one talk
is the Paternoster spin-off
it's not official the BBC hasn't
officially said that they're developing
mud but it feels like every time Moffat
uses them in an episode it's a backdoor
spinoff supposedly he's really pushing
for it in this first episode in series 8
we've all seen the pictures from behind
the scenes in episode 1 but I think I
mentioned in an older video that the
characters are supposed to be featured
at the end of series 8 - I don't know
how they're involved but supposedly they
showed up on a casting sheet from
somewhere in the last few episodes that
makes sense if Moffitt's trying to gain
steam for another spinoff Sarah Jane at
Torchwood were the last big successful
ones I didn't watch Sarah Jane but I was
a huge fan of Torchwood and to anyone
hoping to see Captain Jack again I think
you're gonna be disappointed John
Barrowman has said in a lot of
interviews he never expects to see
Captain Jack on-screen again he said he
was never contacted at any time during
Moffitt's run to appear on any of the
specials or in any of the episodes just
because in his mind Captain Jack was
Russell T Davies baby and Moffat wants
to do his own thing even though you
could argue that the clockwork droids
are both Moffitt's and Davies that's
just John Barrowman talking on his own
though it's up to Moffat who comes back
but here's an interesting question would
you watch a Paternoster spin-off think
about it in terms of the way the
characters are written Doctor Who is a
series that's marketed to children and
Millennials so you do get mature themes
done with a lot of humor and morality
that you see in children's series
Torchwood on the other hand was designed
for an older more mature audience so you
get much more mature subject matter the
Paternoster characters on the other hand
feel like they're written for a younger
audience as if a Paternoster series
would be more for children just rewatch
any scene with Strax in it Madame vastra
and Jenny could go either way but I feel
like Strax is there for children there
was even a moment during series 7 that
the BBC produced some material with
Strax going out to visit children in
classrooms I will go on record as saying
I won't watch anything produced under
the Doctor Who umbrella but Game of
Thrones is my jam so if we get a
Paternoster spin-off I'd like to see
Madame vastra disemboweled someone with
her teeth every once in a while either
way Paternoster gang is definitely here
to stay spin-off or no spin-off the big
character that Moffat said was
definitely gone for good was the master
I know that's a huge bummer earlier this
year there was a lot of reports that the
BBC was screen testing new actors for a
new version of the master right now John
Simm is still technically the master but
his
Cirie's intruders is actually just
getting going so even if he wanted to
return he probably could not Moffitt's
comment was really that he felt Russell
T Davies did such a good job with the
master that he didn't feel like he had
anything to add to it so thus we have no
master in series 8 I don't know anything
about you know who the actual big
villain is of series 8 supposedly
there's someone teased in that first
episode that's a little familiar I won't
talk about them right now just because I
haven't seen the episode yet but if you
have seen that first episode and you
want to tell us what you think of it
just be sure to use spoiler tags if you
get really specific I know I haven't
mentioned anything about Samuel Anderson
yet he's actually with them on the
Doctor Who world tour right now
supposedly he's gonna debut in the third
or fourth episode but I think he's gonna
be a lot of fun just based on what
people are saying onto the giveaway
congratulations to last week's winners
Bob Orton and simply Maya beautiful you
guys both went Amazon giftcards I know I
said the giveaway was for one person but
I'm so happy the BBC is giving me
shoutouts that I'm doubling it sometimes
if I'm super happy I'll just like double
or triple giveaways totally randomly I
usually don't announce things like that
I just get really happy and say I'll
just give extra stuff away and just to
explain that BBC request I got they saw
my beginner's guide video and thought
that it would be fun to do the same
thing for classic ooh so that's what my
next video is gonna be mostly it's just
gonna draw from the third and fourth
doctor's runs but it's gonna be a giant
list from all a classic who so be sure
to subscribe to get that and if you
haven't seen it yet you can click here
to watch my series eight beginner's
guide just if you're not familiar with
Doctor Who and click here to learn all
about the new companions I'd like to see
in series 9 thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives
you